"
♪ ♪
JOE BIDEN SAYS THE MOST
IMPORTANT ELECTION IN OUR
LIFETIME IS EIGHT DAYS AWAY, BUT
HE IS KICKING HIS FEET UP IN
DELAWARE WITH VIOLATING HIS
FORMER BOSS DO ALL THE
WORK
WHILE LETTING HIS FORMER BOSS DO
ALL THE WORK.
M.I.A. FROM THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL,
DEMOCRATS ARE TURNING TO
BARACK OBAMA TO RESCUE THEM FROM
A MIDTERM SHELLACKING, THE GUY
WHO LOST -- THE BEST HOPE TO
STOP THIS RED WAVE.
>> THE ONLY WAY TO SAVE
DEMOCRACY IS IF WE NURTURE IT
AND FIGHT FOR IT TOGETHER.
THAT STARTS WITH COLLECTING
PEOPLE WHO KNOW YOU AND SEE YOU
AND CARE ABOUT YOU.
EVERY REPUBLICAN POLITICIAN
SEEMS OBSESSED WITH TWO THINGS:
OWN THE LIVES.
THEY ARE --
ONLY LIBS.
THEY ARE INTERESTED IN MAKING
YOU ANGRY.
THEY ARE HOPING IT WILL DISTRACT
YOU FROM THE FACT THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE ANSWERS OF THEIR OWN.
>> EVEN THE MEDIA REALIZES THAT
BIDEN IS --
AT THEIR WORST CUSTOMER.
HE CAN'T BE OUT THERE, SO THIS
IS THE ONLY PERSON THEY CAN PUT
OUT.
>> THE DEMOCRATS HOPE HE IS A
CLOSER.
I TALKED TO TWO PEOPLE YESTERDAY
AND REGULAR CONVERSATIONS.
BARACK OBAMA IS GOOD AT THIS,
AND I THINK THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE
COUNTING ON, ESPECIALLY FOR --
>> WE NEED THOSE MILLENNIALS,
THE GEN ZS.
HE ENERGIZES YOUNG PEOPLE IN THE
BASE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
LIKE NOBODY ELSE APPEARED >> THE
WHITE HOUSE IS GOING FULL BAG
DOWN ON BIDEN, INSISTING THAT HE
IS OUT THERE CAMPAIGNING --
>> WHY IS THE FORMER PRESIDENT
MAKING THIS CASE AND NOT THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT?
>> I WOULD DISAGREE WITH THAT
CHARACTERIZATION OF YOUR
QUESTION TRE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THIS ON MOST EVERY DAY FOR
MONTHS NOW.
HE'S BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE
CHOICES THAT ARE AT STAKE HERE,
WHICH I WAS -- WHICH IS WHAT
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO DO.
>> DANA PERINO, WHAT DID YOU
THINK OF BARACK OBAMA'S MESSAGE?
>> I THINK OBVIOUSLY, HE CAN
STILL RALLY THE BASE, AND MOST
OF THE DEMOCRATS WHO WENT TO
THOSE EVENTS THINKING THERE WAS
NOT AN AMENDMENT THAT SAID HE
COULDN'T RUN FOR A THIRD TERM --
THEY WOULD RATHER HAVE HIM DO
IT.
WHEN JOE BIDEN SAYS THIS IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT ELECTION IN OUR
LIFETIME, WHAT HE MEANS IS IT IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT ELECTION IN
HIS LIFETIME, BECAUSE THE
OUTCOME WILL DEFINE HIS LEGACY
AND FATE.
IF IT'S A WASHOUT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, THEN ALL IS A WASH,
AT 12:01 ON ELECTION NIGHT,
EVERYONE WILL TURN TO 2524 AND
THE QUESTION WILL BE IF HE WILL
RUN AGAIN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS LEFT WITH
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS TO
WORK WITH, WHICH IS NOT A
COHERENT ECONOMIC MESSAGE.
WHAT THEY'VE TRIED TO DO IS SAY
"WE DROVE THE CAR IN THE DITCH,
BUT YOU SHOULD LET US KEEP
DRIVING."
BUT HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT, WE ARE
IN THE DITCH.
THERE WAS SOMETHING INTERESTING
IN THAT CBS POLL THAT CAME OUT.
OBAMA AND BIDEN HAVE TRIED TO
SAY THAT THE REPUBLICANS HAVE NO
IDEAS, NO PLAN, THAT THEY ARE
JUST OUT THERE SAYING THEY WILL
DO SOMETHING BUT WON'T.
IN THIS FIRST POLL, 59% OF
VOTERS SAY THAT DEMOCRATS HAD A
CLEAR PLAN ON WHAT THEY WOULD DO
TO KEEP POWER, 55% -- THAT'S NOT
GOOD FOR EITHER PARTY, BUT IT
DOES SHOW YOU THAT DEMOCRATS WHO
SPENT THIS TIME AND MONEY ON
ABORTION, JANUARY 6TH, AND
SAYING THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
WORSE OR DON'T HAVE A PLAN, THAT
MESSAGE HAS NOT STOPPED.
>> MAYBE HE'S GOT IT ALL FIGURED
OUT: RELAX AND HAVE YOUR OLD
BOSS DOING THE WORK.
>> I DON'T THINK HE KNOWS HE'S
BEING IGNORED.
I THINK THEY HAVE COMPETING
EVENTS ON A SOUNDSTAGE.
I THINK HE'S CONVINCED HE'S OUT
THERE CAMPAIGNING AND HAS NO
IDEA.
YOU HAVE TO STOP TALKING ABOUT
SHELLACKING.
I'M TELLING ALL OF MY LIBERAL
FRIENDS -- NOT TO FALL FOR THIS
RED WAVE STUFF.
IT'S ALL EXAGGERATION.
YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE TO VOTE.
[LAUGHTER]
THERE IS NO WAY THAT FEDERMAN,
CARY LAKE OR HERSCHEL WALKER IS
GOING TO WIN.
I'M SO PESSIMISTIC ABOUT THE
REPUBLICANS THAT I BELIEVE THE
DEMOCRATS SHOULD HAVE A
PRE-ELECTION PARTY MONDAY NIGHT,
JUST GET BOMBED, TOTALLY BOMBED,
SLEEP IN TUESDAY, DON'T EVEN
BOTHER.
WHAT UPSETS ME ABOUT OBAMA IS
THERE TWO OBAMA'S: THE OBAMA WHO
SPOKE SENSE A COUPLE OF WEEKS
AGO TALKING ABOUT HOW DEMOCRATS
SHOULD BE HAPPIER OR BE NICER
AND GET RID OF THIS WOKE STUFF,
AND THEN EVERYTHING HE JUST SAID
THERE IS THE OPPOSITE.
IT'S THE KIND OF TWITTER
HYPERBOLE, SAVING DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S WHAT THE CRAZY PEOPLE
SAY.
THAT IS FOR MAX BOOT GAME
JENNIFER RUBIN.
IT'S NOT FOR YOU.
AND THEN THE "OWNING THE LIBS"
THING: THAT IS TWITTER SPEAK.
HE BASICALLY CUT HIMSELF INTO
TWO OBAMA'S, AND I FOUND THAT
KIND OF SAD.
IT'S WEIRD TO BE IN A PARTY
WHERE YOU DON'T WANT THE PEOPLE
VOTING FOR YOU TO SEE WHO LEADS
THE PARTY.
IT REMINDS ME OF THE "HOUSE OF
CARDS," WHERE KEVIN SPACEY, THE
SCANDAL DESTROYED THE FRENCH ARE
SO THEY THOUGHT THEY COULD DO
THE SHOW WITHOUT HIM.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE DOING WITH
JOE.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
WORK.
>> KATIE WORK YOU INSPIRED WHEN
YOU SAW A CROWD INSPIRED TO
BARACK OBAMA?
THAT WAS MORE THAN I'VE EVER
SEEN AT A BIDEN RALLY.
>> HE WAS TRYING TO PACE OUT
LATE IN THE GAME, BUT HE'S ALSO
INSPIRING THE BASE WHO IS OUT
THERE AS WELL.
PRESIDENT OBAMA DOESN'T HAVE A
LOT OF CREDIBILITY WHEN IT COMES
TO MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR SAYING "WE
GOT SHELLACKED," AFTER THE 2012
ELECTION.
AFTER PUSHING THROUGH HUGE
PIECES, ALLOWING
TRANSFORMATIONAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION FOR THE COUNTRY
WITHOUT A SINGLE REPUBLICAN
VOTE, NO BIPARTISANSHIP.
WHEN IT COMES TO HIS ARGUMENT IN
THIS SPEECH, HE CLAIMS THAT
REPUBLICANS ARE TRYING TO "MAKE
ME ANGRY, THEY CLAIM THEY ARE
DOING THIS THING WHERE THEY ARE
INSULTING -- AS IF THEY DON'T
KNOW WHAT THEY ARE GOING FOR,
THAT THE ISSUES OF THE ECONOMY,
INFLATION'S ON CRIME EFFECT HIM
--" IN A WAY THAT ARE NOT
REPUBLICANS MAKING THEM ANGRY.
THEY ARE ANGRY BECAUSE THEIR
STREETS ARE NOT SAFE.
FOR DEMOCRATS TO REPEATEDLY SAY
"REPUBLICANS IF THEY TRY TO MAKE
YOU ANGRY ABOUT THINGS THAT
DON'T EXIST ACCORDING TO US --"
I DON'T THINK THAT WILL WORK
WHEN IT COMES TO INDEPENDENT
VOTERS WHO ARE STILL ON THE
FENCE UP UNTIL ELECTION DAY,
ESPECIALLY AMONG PEOPLE WHO
ARE -- TALKING ABOUT VOTING
BASED ON THE TALK ISSUES FOR
REPUBLICANS.
SPEAK OF SPEAK TO KATIE'S POINT.
--
>> SPEAK TO KATIE'S POINT.
NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
IS THAT REALLY WHAT'S HAPPENING?
IS THE COUNTRY ANGRY BECAUSE
GREG GUTFELD HAS MADE THEM
ANGRY, OR LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS
MADE THEM ANGRY?
OR, ARE THEY ANGRY BECAUSE
THERE'S A CRIME WAVE, OPEN
BORDER, EVERYTHING?
>> WELL MOSTLY ABOUT INFLATION
AND CRIME.
THAT CAN CUT AWAY TO A LOT: WE
WILL TALK ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
RACE HERE IN NEW YORK,
PENNSYLVANIA IS OBVIOUSLY A HUGE
ISSUE, WISCONSIN WHERE
PRESIDENT OBAMA WAS FEATURED.
I WATCHED BOTH RALLIES, I WAS IN
GEORGIA OVER THE WEEKEND.
THE ENERGY WAS HUGE FOR ALL OF
THEM.
PEOPLE ARE FIRED UP.
IT'S ALWAYS EXCITING TO ME IN A
SWING STATE WHERE YOUR VOTE
MATTERS AND HAVING THAT HAPPEN
THAT OFTEN.
>> EXCEPT FOR THIS YEAR.
>> WE WILL SEE HOW SWINGING IT
IS.
>> I THOUGHT OBAMA'S MESSAGE WAS
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT HE WAS
SAYING ABOUT STAYING AWAY FROM
IT.
HE TALKED ABOUT A LOT OF OTHER
ISSUES THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAD TALKED ABOUT.
HE ACKNOWLEDGED INFLATION AND
SAID IT'S BAD ALL OVER THE
WORLD, BUT DON'T SAY IT ISN'T
BAD, AND THE ONE THING HE HITS
THAT I DON'T UNDERSTAND -- IT'S
AT THE CORE OF THE DEMOCRATIC
MESSAGE.
WHAT IF RICK SCOTT'S PLAN GOES
INTO EFFECT FOR MEDICARE AND
SOCIAL SECURITY?
THERE IS A MINUTE AND A HALF
CLIP ABOUT HIM TALKING ABOUT
SOCIAL SECURITY AND HOW PEOPLE
IN WISCONSIN WORKED THEIR WHOLE
LIVES TO GET THAT MONEY, AND
REPUBLICANS GET INTO OFFICE,
THEY WILL SCALE BACK
ENTITLEMENTS, AND I DON'T KNOW
WHY DEMOCRATS AREN'T LEADING
WITH THAT.
>> AND IT'S NOT TRUE.
>> A REPUBLICAN PRESIDENT
RECENTLY HAS ATTACKED, GONE
AFTER, AND REDUCED
SOCIAL SECURITY?
NO ONE.
>> ANY REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTS IN
THE LAST 50 YEARS CUSTOMER
THERE'S BEEN QUITE A LOT, BUT
THEY'VE NEVER DONE WHAT THEY ARE
ALWAYS BEING ACCUSED OF.
>> RICK SCOTT'S PLAN >> --
>> THERE ISN'T ANOTHER --
>> BUT HE PUT OUT THE PLAN AS
FAR AS REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO
DO.
MITCH McCONNELL SAID "I HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT," BUT HE
DID NOT PUT HIS PLAN FORWARD.
SO YOU TELL ME "WHAT'S THE BIG
REPUBLICAN PLANT?
>> WHAT'S IT CALLED AGAIN?
>> COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.